[Music]
welcome back new rockstars guys I'm bill
Molina this is rogue theory we were
gonna go to figure out I'm already drunk
we're gonna figure out who will make up
the next version of The Avengers broke
there by the way is a show that we would
bring people together that are very fun
and we get their ideas on all kinds of
theories and topics and whatever's on
our minds on today's episode we have
course in roxarsone Erik Bosse hello we
also have Jeff McCubbin of the comic
book queers podcast hello yeah and then
we also have welcome back to Angelica
Trey aka tray on Twitch not a train
which is a very bad but it's scenic we
should have more of a gas country guys a
reminder that you can listen to the show
on the road theory podcast fee to get it
earlier than you would get it on the
video also this episode is going to be
about all kinds of rogue theories as
they all are we're gonna hit up an
upcoming DC movie yeah what do you see
and we're gonna talk about some fast and
furious Universal and all kinds of
whatnot but first let's just get right
into it the New Avengers so Kevin Feige
said in an interview that there will be
another Avengers that's probably not the
shock just like yeah he's they're gonna
make more billions and then the group is
going to contain some characters that we
know and some that we don't so or maybe
we haven't met yet right so I want us to
go down the line and I just want to be
pitched on what this New Avengers team
probably will be based on your guests
for where maybe face five is gonna go or
if you also just like you know who it
needs to be and I got a real hot take
and then you're just like you just say
characters that don't exist I don't know
but yeah let's go first I'll go first
oh I thought about this wait no way too
much that is healthy I'm convinced that
they're gonna go the route of Brian
Michael Bendis
New Avengers run because it is the New
Avengers because New Avengers had
Captain America in it but that would be
that Falcon I think but then he also had
a Wolverine on his team
he had a spider-man on his team he had a
Luke Cage I think they're gonna throw in
a blade since they announced him and
then I think we're gonna add a Jessica
drew who is Spider Woman that's who I
think is pretty good
yeah yeah so why do you think they're
going what they would go the New
Avengers right well because I also think
they're gonna have the Scarlet Witch and
I think the Scarlet Witch there in the
New Avengers when she goes crazy and
starts killing everybody and and that
leads to house of M which is all with
the mutants and I think that's maybe how
they're gonna bring the mutants into the
Marvel Cinematic Universe
yeah because it seems like what are
their broader goals what do they need
this new Avengers lineup to do and their
films and if you think now they have the
x-men this new avengers could be set up
in order to tie in a lot of these new
characters so that we can reboot them
and yeah i think we're gonna see house
of em at some point in this last week we
were like all about that's gotta be how
they bring in the mutants except for a
number of different ways that they also
a great way to do it especially because
of one division yeah supposedly being
tied into the dark strange maybe it
feels right yeah what's your pitch I I
agree with the Falcon I could see Falcon
I think can we're keeping people right
can we keep yeah okay and then I want
kind of a ragtag group here so I'd like
to see some maybe like a Negative Nancy
in here can we get like a Jessica Jones
or a Nebula do you think existing
Jessica Jones they actually are like you
know what we'll go back and we'll save
someone from the Netflix world sure why
not rip Netflix but yeah I would love to
see that and then maybe like the thing
yeah I had a similar thought when I get
to my now say but I honestly I cannot
get over
fact I don't think even Marvel will be
able to really pull off what the thing
should look like and I just don't know
the like you want to put him in that I
mean people gonna disagree with me but
he's poop
he's like standing it made of poop logs
and poop links I'm like it'll be funny
like no but it shouldn't be it should be
intimidating but it's just like
something about the cracks like a
condensed pine cone like if a pine cone
got nervous and scared and shrunken
scared do I harden so piss on how that
group operates together I I kind of just
want like that weird group dynamic like
that's what I like is the awkwardness of
just a total different group of
personalities so I'd love to see someone
that's you know very you know morally
upstanding and then you know maybe like
a little more roguish characters in
there you know if there's like a nebula
Jessica Jones type character it would be
very negative Nancy
sort of you're you know in the group I
just love seeing those interactions it's
my favorite part is just based on the
Winnie the Pooh animals and like Phillip
said an awkward Avengers you could tell
it that just like stuffed animals
brought to life in the mind of a child
which is what these are they are toys
who save cities and planets
yeah like when the one the villain is
monologuing they're just like you know
what you're right what are we doing
[Music]
oh yeah I don't like it and I will not
see this film
what if it's titled awkward Avengers
awkward adventures imagine if the big
battle team at moment they say Avengers
it seems like the way phase 3 left off
in the wave phase 4 is taking over we're
kind of in this thematic era of a lack
of trust and not knowing what you can
believe so think how far for a moment
admits boiler warning for far from home
because it apparently takes people four
months to see the movie like you had
this thing where you have Mysterio's
fake news you have Spider Man kind of
made into a public enemy you also have
this whole weird scroll conspiracy where
the scrolls are now working with Nick
Fury's operation and we don't know where
the hell Nick Fury is and then what are
the first two things coming out from
face worried of Black Widow a story
about spy espionage and potentially a
new double agent taking over for Natasha
Romanov maybe in the Elena Bulova and
then you have falcon Winter Soldier
which sounds like it might be about not
trusting this new version of Captain
America you have a government who still
considers Winter Soldier and cap enemies
of the state unless they got pardons
which they definitely deserve after what
they've done in India but so maybe what
the New Avengers role will be in phase
four and Beyond will be restoring the
public trust in superheroes because if
you think I can imagine a lot of people
blaming superheroes the way spider-man
is now about to be blamed and I have
this theory in a new Falcon Winter
Soldier of Zemo story because we know
Baron Zemo is coming back that he might
do a Thunderbolts style plot and present
these villains as the New Avengers to
fill the void and then over time they
turn on him and they become good people
Goliath is a good guy so we might see
something like that right like maybe we
have rip dem
of characters people like Winter Soldier
people like Yelena Bulova people like
spider-man who people aren't really sure
whether or not they can trust and this
new version of the Avengers in phase
four will be these kind of like antihero
figures from the public's perspective
and their goal will be to avenge the
lack of trust that people have now
having superheroes on earth and then
maybe we'll have other lineups of people
to handle galactic cosmic problems what
I want who's in here who's in your line
so this lineup would be Falcon
spider-man
maybe Winter Soldier maybe Elena Bulova
maybe banner Hulk since I don't really
see him going off world that much this
version of him I think his sacar
adventures are over and then maybe
characters like blade like characters
who are earthbound whereas I see dr.
strange Wanda Maximoff and in all the
guardians of the galaxy Thor they're
gonna be off doing other
interdimensional adventures and
intergalactic adventures that's my idea
of where I think is and what uh what's
what storyline any potentially housing
this so I mentioned scrolls Secret
Invasion is what we're all kind of
waiting for right and in this next phase
Captain Marvel seems to be kind of
hinting at it and that post-credits
scene for far from home seems to be
hinting at this idea that a lot of the
heroes we know might be squirrel
shapeshifters and in disguise I have a
video series that I'm obsessed with and
going through every character in the MCU
to figure out which of them could be
Scrolls and making a case for why this
person might have been actually a scroll
the whole time so if you have the whole
time if you bring in this idea of the
Secret Invasion where the society is
doesn't know what to believe they have
these conspiracy theories that trust of
government officials and superheroes
might have been these alien
shapeshifters and then the Avengers that
they've known and loved have let them
down in some ways the way that we move
on and move through secret invasion is
how this New Avengers team gets formed
it's at the end of the day worthy
Avengers you can trust and they have to
earn it to fight to earn back and prove
their humanity to society don't you
think it's hard to do Secret Invasion
with the Skrulls being good but it's the
same thing as the Kree have already been
shown to have their divisions like I
think it's just realistic to humanity
you know
like we're not all good people deep down
I know you're afraid to eyelid you think
that they're just gonna be like some of
us are bad yeah yeah I have like a
splinter cell of scroll extremists the
way that you know we have Talos and his
crew were kind of like good guys who've
worked with humans and project Pegasus
and they work with fury you could have
some who are more like the Ronin of the
Star Trek does it right yeah like
they're just the different races there's
always kind of like the the fascists or
whatever they're they're the extremist
groups in there yeah most of the
villains tend to be like some race that
we know really well but one extremists
within that race that just normally
actually most of the races are into war
thinking Cardassian right now okay
so I'm down with with Secret Invasion
and I'm mostly done with most of you
guys is line up I have similar ideas for
lineup wise I like I kind of like New
Avengers as a bit of a model but I would
keep Sam doing kind of like other cap
related stuff and then really just have
Bucky take on the Winter Soldier like
name again honestly but he fills in that
cap role so he's on my team I'll throw
out that he has spider-man like the kids
got so many years Hostel still left on
him so he's he's great I think yeah like
Captain Marvel is probably the Thor
replacement or something by this point
we're talking phase 5 - yeah so it's
like you know who knows whose contracts
or not up or hasn't died in some way or
another and then I oh I really like
Wolverine being on there which is also
borrowing from that story but also just
like if they're gonna bring the x-men in
how do you not then like start throwing
them into also the Avengers and in that
same vein I'll give you a Sue Storm all
right I also would say like maybe like
mr. fantastic or Human Torch or
something but I just wanted another
woman on the on the crew I think feels
right so thrown Sue Storm and then
here's my big swing
danos what
he's good right now I know specifically
it's a multiverse version of Thanos and
it's because we are in a phase five
where we're doing the annihilation story
where specifically danos is like hey you
know so Annihilus wants to destroy all
life in the universe and that multiverse
is Santos is like I don't want the Hat
and I really like I really feel like we
might get a bad guy on the good guy team
coming up so and like who has a we've
already done it too much with Loki and
Thanos is like such a like rich villain
that I would love to be able to see him
again and imagine him being on their
side almost like a whole kind of role or
something it's very fun I'll also throw
out there that I think maybe they're
getting their direct directions from
Professor X and Doctor Strange as a
representation of the Illuminati I like
the idea of the Illuminati and that
brings the idea of maybe Namor yeah
coming include him only because he's
like yeah sure like like a lot of
brilliant minds could be could be there
but part of me feels like the MCU might
be like you know what it's weird if they
like have this meeting and they call
themselves especially ik now the
Illuminati is a little bit of a like a
dorky thing imagine if they were like
the Illuminati yeah it's we haven't
really talked about how Black Panther
will fit in with any new Avengers lineup
I think no matter what the Avengers are
going to be the group of people in the
Marvel Universe who care the most about
defending and protecting earth I think I
don't think the Avengers are gonna care
too much about what's happening outside
of Earth and you got to think like you
know the new role that T'Challa has in
this version of the MCU he's just
revealed his nation to the world and
they are basically the world's
superpower they have the most advanced
weaponry they're the most
technologically advanced so you kind of
imagine him being not just king of
Wakanda but like king of the world like
the most trusted government like they
house division there they were the most
secure nation to protect vision and
didn't work but you know that's where
they go so I think he's gonna have to be
in some kind of lineup whatever the mix
is it's either gonna be him or
representative from what kind of like
Sheree so just to keep tally rapid-fire
list off who your team is okay so I
think we got spider-man
think we got Black Panther Falcon
whoever the new Black Widow is whether
it's the Alina Bulova or someone from
that world and banner Hulk and blade I'm
now updating it from what everyone said
but I yeah I'm going for Falcon Scarlet
Witch Spider Woman spider-man Wolverine
and Luke Cage and then I think Black
Panther as well nice okay
I'll add one new person in their bag
okay fine I'll go to my original Falcon
I think I said I said the thing I want
nebula or Jessica Jones I want someone
that's cranky and then I wanna go I
think so busy thinking about night
monkey because I miss monkey the night
monkey version of spider-man exactly
like night monkey by night and
spider-man by day was I was Captain
Marvel Sue Storm Wolverine spider-man
Bucky Thanos yeah and then you know just
being led by Doctor Strange I'm
Professor X okay thinking your team for
second just be honest with yourself
whose team would defeat all the other
teams my team would get its ass kicked I
think you're only saying this because
you know you have Thanos just reminding
you also Professor X is just like
hanging out though actually but Yura
Thanos is the opposite so your thinnest
like wants to double the population no
that's not how a bizarro Thanos so he's
probably super peaceful and well I like
there's also like to vulvar eenz on our
teams that think spider-man is fighting
spider-man
I want to see that movie yeah spider-man
vs. biting spider-man
so yeah fine
you win for no reason yeah one of the
Avengers yeah you know I'm not that's
kind of I'm starting to get your brand
by the way with the awkward was it
awkward adventures and they have an
awkward advantage
maybe that's what as we all kill each
other often you're the only ones left
that feels like like guys it's speaking
of this show these people help us bring
this show I think is what we're going to
add yeah sponsors this episode of rogue
theory is brought to you by new rock
stars and the word more as in way more
new rock stars content how exciting is
that that's amazing we are about to blow
you away
whoo it's uh I'm glad I said the word
away there that could have been a very
precarious sentence but we are going to
blow you away with how much new stuff we
have coming it's going to be a real big
surprise a lot of us but also it doesn't
mean that we're getting rid of anything
else we're just expanding growing some
just exciting new stuff is coming your
way and we just kind of wanted to start
dropping some hints that some of those
things might be coming soon and some a
little later but I guess maybe hit
number one is that might get some
questions answered real soon
that's all back to the show we're back
guys there was potential maybe possibly
leaked plot for Falcon in the Winter
Soldier yes dude did you see it yeah are
you lying
I saw the whole show basically the
theoretical maybe it's a leak maybe it's
not actually potential spoilers ahead if
this is a actually and then people
always like you say spoilers and then
you don't give me enough time to hit
pause so this time that I'm talking
right now you could have hit pause Aaron
all right and now going into it so
potentially the story's going to be
about the government not actually
wanting Sam to take
/ they come in America mantle which like
them getting involved in that is kind of
a weird choice in the first place yeah
but there is that comic storyline of Sam
not wanting to be connected to the
government that it feels too kind of
like linked to a bureaucracy and it kind
of confused him the wrong way
so him going independent is actually a
comic related thing but so I just want
to know from you guys if you think that
maybe that storyline if they go that way
is the appropriate way to do this are
you I would that excite you that there's
gonna be about this idea that like maybe
the Captain America mantle actually he's
come start drifting away from
bureaucracy or government or are you
like nah dawg like like I wish he would
just play exactly Cap symbolism
patriotism seperating yeah basically
yeah well yeah I I like that I like that
level of conflict here because we view
you know superheroes as the most
powerful and then we view our government
as something that has previously or
maybe currently I don't know is super
powerful as well and so having those two
things come to a head is a really
interesting dynamic for me so I'm
excited yeah so you want that you want
it to be fine basically the role yes
yeah kind of how he was a little
incident civil war - yeah it's kind of
following Winter Soldier in Civil War
where cap was like well I don't want to
be a poster child for a government
that's doing things that I don't believe
in we saw in Civil War and Winter
Soldier the government was had been
compromised by Hydra anyway I don't
think we ever really dealt with Sam
Wilson's reaction to the events of civil
war where he was imprisoned in the raft
and I think everyone on Team cap fell
like since a distrust in the government
and in Tony Stark and it was just the
events of infinitive or an end game that
kind of brought them all back together
from circumstance but I think that's
something maybe the Black Widow movie
might deal with because that's gonna be
set before infinity war it's gonna be
set between civil war and infinity war
so hopefully like through Black Widow
and her story we can also get a sense of
how Sam might feel from being betrayed
by his government and maybe he won't
really want to the way Captain and he
might want to leave that behind and keep
the shield but
kind of define what the shield will mean
and maybe put a different emblem on it
all I want to know what the Black Widow
movie is how her hair ended up looking
like I got a theory Gil Elena believe oh
really look
yeah it's because it's her natural hair
color and during the snap it's such a
depressing pair she stops coloring it is
more that's not enough for five years
and like that like that much I think how
damaged is her hair I think we need to
do Studies on this but going off what
you said I think in general Marvel works
better when the characters are outcasts
I think DC is the good like where the
golden boys we work with the government
everything's wonderful that's more of a
Superman II thing I think the side of
Marvel can't eat this ice cream I gotta
go fight aliens but yeah i think i think
the avengers work best when they're
outcasts and they're and and the general
population does not like them yeah
agreed I really like that you brought up
Superman because that actor needs work
because Superman and Captain America are
both trying to they try to make them the
symbolism of America's is engrained in
that character supposedly at its core
but I actually very much like that the
boy scout Superman is kind of like you
know what I trust my parents I had a
good life and I trust my government and
that caps like yeah me too and then he's
put through the wringer but he's like
wait well I'm not stupid and so it
actually even though it's which would
switch over to Sam I really like the
idea that it's the arc of the character
of Captain America starts from he's
literally propaganda
right initially like the air and they
use him and in stupid videos and whatnot
and he has to film those fake war/battle
see a bunch and Hitler and yeah exactly
to inspire people and then he's so he's
literally used as a tool all the way
through like you know it didn't
necessarily finish with Steve Rogers but
he does really come to distrust someone
do something to now when he hands it
over to Sam he's like yeah no I'm not
even gonna play that game at all from
the beginning one interesting thing that
I hope happens because you were talking
about Thunderbolts and all of that stuff
I think it'll be very interesting and
it's like in the comic books there was a
period where Lake Norman Osborn started
to rise the ranks in the government and
I don't know he didn't become president
at some point yeah but I like that idea
of a villain being in like the head of
the government which we've seen some of
that they've laid the groundwork with
figures like Alexander Pierce being and
Hydra figures rising to secretary of
state and these things yeah and there
are multiple senators that were in it'll
be interesting to see how like a Secret
Invasion cation with that like some one
of the other figures some people have
tweeted at me like look into Thunderbolt
Ross you know he's kind of the now the
face of the government in the MCU
he's Secretary of State now I think
currently unless something happened
during the blip that we don't know about
I know but but he's also representative
of the military and I think that's
almost like the too easy right where
it's like the Colonel Kurtz kind of
thing of like oh that guy's gone crazy
and now he's on his own warpath
instead I like the the sleeper you know
mayor Pete kind of person is like like
he's got like you know the sleeves
rolled up he's like I'm working for you
but secretly I'm actually like super
evil we've had problems with sane
presidential candidates are actually
green alien figures guys no may repeats
a very fun smart person sure he's
watching
I mean probably those I'll talk about
the politics do Rockstar yeah
stay in your lane yeah so we decide yeah
we're down with that right like it yeah
yeah also you know what my biggest
frustration with civil war was that they
didn't I don't think they did a great
job of going kind of underground
specifically with cap right cap having
meetings and sewers and stuff in the
comics is like so fascinating to me of
just like you like think you're like
you're you're this you're in this alter
where people have all this respect for
you and now you're like in a literal
sewer with like you know crap on your
feet or whatever like rats or anybody
like this is what your government thinks
of you that you have to like us so put
the same story through that we're like
he's kind of on the run or yeah Sam
Wilson as the forgotten veteran like how
many homeless veterans do we have in
this country how many veterans have we
forgotten and have like opioid abuse and
mental problems and he could maybe be an
emblem of that structure and tonally the
fugitive right it's kind of that thing
of like look I'm trying to like solve
this one thing stay out of my way I'm
gonna I'm gonna stay in hiding a little
bit really interesting yeah and those
remember how much experience Sam has
with these leading group therapy
sessions he understands that side of
post-war life for a lot of vets more
than really any other MCU characters
I'll say this darker a little drier
place is also the when you're like oh
that doesn't sound like marble that's
Winter Soldier yeah right when Winter
Soldier came out it was that spy
thriller and yeah had that kind of it
was even shot desaturated yeah not like
it was like slightly less colorful than
your average film that sounds like
perfect it also sounds like the way that
you make a TV show that isn't as
expensive as a movie yeah it's like well
every scene is in the sewers one suicide
yeah alright so we solved it and we know
that it's gonna be great and if we sign
our approval yeah to judge me all right
send it off yeah other thing that people
are talking about right now and I want
your guy's opinion on
is about Darkseid and so we're gonna go
into DC here for a second so I if you
hate that skip this yes sometimes we
should like it uses like yes fantastic
character yeah I'm really into DC
characters they also by the by you know
come up with great characters and
sometimes it's Marvel later that has a
similar character so sometimes with the
same names yeah yeah so I want to go
into so Ava Duvernay said this week that
her New Gods movie would feature
Darkseid and that character is
constantly compared to Thanos they look
a lot alike they also have that kind of
like the the treatment of there's no
villain beyond I mean there are but
that's the way they're they're seen as
like the main biggest bill and
considering DC's like not missteps but
they're hard out of the gate time that
they've had of trying to get a ride and
maybe we should copy Marvel maybe we
shouldn't one now are they gonna be in a
situation is dark side too similar to
Thanos yeah sadly yes I think based off
what we know about dark side from the
comics and what's really got to be
freshman for a lot of DC Comics fans his
dark side came first like jim Starlin
created the character of Thanos but like
yeah he wanted to give Marvel their
version and this was happening
throughout the 60s and 70s on both sides
where you know they're these competing
comic companies they're like we should
have our version of this and but yeah
they're both purple
they're both jacked they're both Old
Testament gods and they're both from
other planets and they've come to earth
in this quest to try to master all power
of the Universe they gave Thanos new
motivation yes it almost makes you
wonder if they were like you know we
need to make him very specific so that
he if they do end up because it was part
of Zack Snyder's plan to have Darkseid
be the villain of eventually in the
Justice League had Darkseid waving at
them from the other side of the boom
tube yeah yeah there was about there all
the Justice League the final shot was
supposed to look up through the boom
tube and he see Darkseid not waving at
them just like looming silhouette yeah I
feel you can't tell a new god story
without Darkseid but
I think and I know they're not going to
do this they should just make him look
different yeah I think they should just
interpretation yeah so what's a Pichet
what does he look like I think he should
just be like long and gangly I was
thinking like side of the road like oh
[Music]
yeah they could do they could replace
him with snagglepuss because he's
actually part of the DC Universe now
yeah they actually released a
snagglepuss
that completes our obligations look at
the opening credits that's the clip of
me show with my name but I'll say the
one thing the New Gods have they have
granny goodness weird S&M oh grandma
evil like genocide I'll kill her now in
fur of yours I don't know an S&M grandma
oh of course they exist well I mean I
mean grandmas now are like much younger
that like that age has now you can be a
grandma and still be you know grandmom
there's a high rate of sexually
transmitted diseases in nursing homes
there are MTV generation grandmas ya
know like some my stuff into a nursing
home
somebody can check this map you can be
36 years old and be a grandma you can be
way younger than 36 and be a grandma I
mean if we're just kids having kids
I'm saying yikes we often have people
recommend to a segments we should cut so
how do you think they'll bring her in I
will say I watched the the cartoon the
it which ones issues in Young Justice
she's currently in there she actually
like is the president of like a video
game like but it's secretly it's like
one of those VR video games and it's
actually like what is it called like
brainwashing them
and and that's how she was entered into
that yeah I think she could come in as
like this nice little grandma so like a
normal yeah like like it's a facade that
story you just told me reminded me of
like almost like a something like what
they like hide the character and some
sort of stupid game or something so you
think like just treat her like a human
that secretly is devoted to dark sides
yeah that's interesting
and what about changing darkside in ways
that are not to make him look more like
Jeff McCullen I do like the idea though
of making him more of a man like he
doesn't need to be that bloated figure
that he is he could be kind of a Silver
Surfer ass kind of humanoid with you
know still oh my guys you know they DC
could learn some lessons for the ways
Marvel adapted Thanos for the screen I
mean the the Marvel Comics version at
the analyst is kind of a one-dimensional
he's just trying to gather jewelry to
impress mistress death and they made him
an eco-terrorist in the movie you know
like he's he's seen how bad
overpopulation around the universe can
be if it's left unchecked so you could
argue whether or not it's a real legit
plausible hey that solved that problem
but maybe DC could just humanize
Darkseid in a different way so it's not
just about power maybe he has some kind
of political or personal motivations
something like he's trying to gather
mother boxes or whatever his plot is in
order to prevent some greater calamity
from happening so you give him like kind
of a sympathetic journey and
maybe deescalate him from the ultimate
Big Bad ultimate Old Testament villain
of the New Gods and maybe just another
one of that family another like outcast
to Hades figure of the new gods who they
can connect with rather than fight
against II does have to be the villain
in this version of the story I'm just
throwing other alternate ideas out there
that they don't have to go the Thanos
MCU route with Darkseid in the DC world
I'm sure they'll do it'll probably be a
villain honestly they'll probably go
along with that but maybe they'll change
the color a little bit you know like
Johnny Bravo hair or something like that
like homer and Krusty was he did have
his weaknesses there you know and we saw
with his daughters I'm sure they'll give
Darkseid a new set of weaknesses as well
because they know this is a pretty
complex character when you think about
it so I'm sure now now yes yeah so I'm
sure they'll do that as well yeah so I'm
into this idea though specific
motivations I we kind of hopped over
real quick weird how about them the
mother box is not but yeah what else so
put it in in the DC Universe what would
motivate Darkseid you know in a way that
feels unique or interesting is it kind
of just borrowing from like die hard
movies I'm like you know how that
villain always has some sort of plot I'm
gonna make it so that all the nukes go
off so that we learn a lesson or don't
you know like is it just finding some
random motivation like that yeah I mean
backstories that's what they're great
for right just put a flashback in there
to give him context to do this thing
yeah yeah or maybe it's something like
you know he views all of human as some
humanity of some kind of subspecies that
is going to hurt the universe so they
have to be exterminated you know you
gotta apply like what's the darkest
things humanity has done to each other
and how can we heighten that in the form
of a superhero that's always late with
the way you go so you look at history
and there's been you know genocide
there's been a thick cleansing there's
been eco-terrorism there's been
political terrorism there's been
religious war so how are you smile
getting bigger it's my face trying to
balance things should be
oh that's just sounds so depressing I
think it should be something fun like he
wants to be like super famous you're
gonna be a star yeah yeah I like that
better where he's like I want to be
number one I want guys this got weird
enough that now I feel totally fine to
talk instead about Hobbes and Shaw
speaking about just sex and violence
brought together the rock okay so this
is the technically I think the 9th Fast
& Furious movie that that is out there
now which puts it ahead of the Star Wars
main saga by the way as movies so if you
guys have seen seen it yet but in it
basically Aegis Elba is a super villain
like superpower
bill and essentially but also this
franchise has done all kinds of insane
things I you know the rock is able to
bust through his cast by flexing Jason
Statham murdered an entire Hospital like
the whole building even you killed it
and literally she came back from the
dead yes yeah
aja yes you know whatever but basically
can we just acknowledge these are
superhero movies yes this is essentially
an Avengers team this is a para dude
then their airport runways are super
heroic they're like 30 miles long six
ended with with this big 30-minute long
this plane never took off it was though
it was a chase on a runway
so they made a plane a big car and
didn't one of them drive through the
whole of the plane they they they were
able to outrun the plane there was a car
on the plane the car smashed through the
front of the plane and then was able to
drive faster than it and outrun it these
are the best movies of all time they are
fantastic
and we're just talking about how there's
superhero movies or like don't they have
that thing now so this just came out
right you were talking about this
article where they say that they can't
lose a fight and they like count how
many punches they have so they
essentially like that's why they take
like in the movie contract yeah yeah but
I like so that's why they get thrown
through a wall and they don't suffer any
consequences they can't lose that fight
yeah The Wall Street Journal did a whole
like awesome reporting eternal here they
they interviewed people who work on
these sets and they've they've dug into
the contracts of all these of in Diesel
Dwayne the rock Johnson Jason Statham
and they all have different versions of
this where they are not allowed to lose
so they have to find creative ways so
that in these movies they both kind of
win in Hawaii even when they're fighting
each other so like Statham will throw a
grenade and the rock even though he kind
of loses that fight he just grabs a
woman and jumps out of a window with her
and by say
a woman he's also a hero they fight but
then helicopter shows up and fires a
missile atom so then the helicopter is
kind of the guy who spoiled the fight by
splitting it up the rock can't even lay
on the ground at someone's feet his
sister is on all the sets and she'll be
like no we need to have him sitting up
here because the rock doesn't lay
defeated at someone's speed he's ready
to get back up oh yeah you just get like
knocked into like a seated position
really nice raise me out so it makes me
just feel like that's what makes a movie
interesting is when the hero loses and
it makes him want to fight back harder
yeah we get the MCU we have that but we
need another place where people are toys
and just not against each other as much
as possible then do superheroes need to
lose in order to be interesting
it depends what you're going to these
movies for I think Marvel has shown us
that Thor is a far more fascinating
character when he gets knocked down
loses meal near gets as I punched out
gets real fat it's headed straight for
are more interesting Tony Stark and a
lot of his Iron Man three kind of ants
with him getting defeated Pepper saves
him and he's much more interesting like
you said when they're outcast when
they're beaten down when they aren't
just these macho figures Captain America
in Captain America Civil War he walks
away limping from that fight in Gator
infinity war he ends knocked on his ass
you know he's not ready to sit back up
he goes oh god that's like some of the
most interesting visuals we've seen of
these characters so I think and Logan
was my favorite Wolverine movie oh yeah
I think it was my favorite Wolverine
movie and yeah we saw what happened with
him he was he was tortured that whole
time so I think superheroes are more
interesting and have more relatability
when they're beaten down but in terms of
what the Fast & Furious franchise has
become it's just like it's almost an
experiment to see how ridiculous and
inhuman and wrestling like we can make
these characters in that like this
stories just get soap operatic
and we just kind of love it for what it
is so I don't know interesting on a
human level they need to lose
interesting on just a spectacle never
it makes me think of rocky right yeah
say I think we can spoil Rocky I think I
can spoil Rocky
Aaron rocky loses Yeah right and widened
dammit he loses this first one and it's
a it really is the story this that is
important it's the journey that he takes
and it's in fact that he was able to
fight it all and and last in the ring at
all is the whole point Philip you found
the perfect metaphor the MCU is rocky
one the past appears for a prize it's
rocky for where they're both incredibly
jacked
I mean Drago kind of loses but it ends
with him we could questions these are
questions that just come at you what the
speed that I read them bring so so
normal human language but you don't know
what they are I don't know what they say
and we have to come up with some quick
answers some rogue theory answers to
these road questions you guys ready yes
all right
all right so the Fast and Furious
spin-off Hobbes and shock comes out this
week can you tell me if these friends
well I'd spoiled one of these if these
franchises have had more or less movies
than The Fast and Furious
are you ready yeah all right your
options are also I'll say instead which
of these franchises has more than the
Fast and Furious whoever gets the answer
fastest first wins or something
yeah Court wins a quarter mile time all
right Mission Impossible less why well I
do save it to the end Mission Impossible
live-action spider-man movies
transformers Star Trek Star Wars and
then the biggest
for hero team-up of all time the Madea
films I think Madea has more I think
that's the only one yeah yeah because
Star Wars Star Trek Star Trek has more
Star Trek has more live action because
you got to think you had like five of
the original series he had three of the
Picard one we talking series are we
talking films you've had at least three
of the new JJ Abrams Kelvin time line
one so we've definitely had at least
like 10 Star Trek films at least so
let's just tell you real quickly at
Mission Possible has last six Spider Man
has less seven transformers has less
seven Star Trek has 13 Star Trek films
Star Wars I didn't actually say main
saga in this so Star Wars has more yeah
with solo in rogue one yeah and Medea
same nine Medea films just as furious
lana del rey is speaking at the
Hollywood Walk of Fame ceremony for
Guillermo del Toro here's the the
connection there
who else with the name del if somewhere
in their name should have been there we
have lana del rey and guillermo del toro
del close should have been of erisa
I should have been arrested for although
live super a drag queen Bianca Del Rio a
woman married her golden retriever oh
yeah English Morning Show this week what
fictional animal would you consider
marrying night monkey yeah what
fictional animal which you consider
marrying of the Judi Dench cat from the
cats trailer I'd go with a Falkor from
the Nordic mystical can we do you can't
change your answer now you're stuck you
don't
oops to Dunkirk August 3rd is national
mustard day
what's your this is what we're talking
about Nashville today is spider-man
today aboard on my national mustard day
what's your favorite yellow fictional
character can we do Beatrice kiddo
that's the only one I'm gonna take
because I refuse to go on on this
question question ok so spider-man is
the most recognized hero in the world
but a lot of people think it's it's
Batman for some reason spider-man is in
every country there's like a
representation of spider-man it's in so
many languages it's also the most
profitable hero that's ever existed
we all have deep connections to
spider-man what's yours Tobey Maguire
crying that's your spider-man mine is
more similar but more shallow it's when
he first wakes up and discovers his
power and just sees his body that
sparked something my favorite moment
it's not my first spider and memory I
don't know what that was but it's from
spider-man 2 when he stops the train and
he goes and he like does the Christ
Posey like bends the metal of it he's
like got any other bright ideas and
someone just made it into like this like
loop they made a 10 minute loop of just
a good try to stop the train 3 to the
ten of you still watching I thank you so
much for going rogue with us thanks to
you guys so much where can we find you
guys I'm Angelica Trey you can find me
on most social media platforms at AOA YY
t ra e and on Twitch as well as on
instagram at Angelica Trey great Jeff
you can find me on instagram at evil
Jeff or you
go to my podcast on instagram at
comic-book queers sweet and eric what do
we got going this week okay yeah so I
teamed back up with our good pal marina
Mastro's and we went through this idea
of how the hell is vision coming back
for Wanda vision no one seems to know
how he was brought back from the dead we
saw his lifeless gray husk roll around
on the wakandan jungle floor and no one
seems to know how he comes back so
marina and I had a lot of fun going
through different weekend at bernie's we
got that we got some theories on what
how Baron Zemo is coming back to the MCU
and yeah now that the e of interest
endgame digital download is out there we
can finally go through frame by frame
and see all the details and in that
final battle there's so much fun things
I saw it four times and still there's
little things that I'm discovering so I
look forward to kind of doing a rewrite
we well yeah you guys gonna go into what
Spider Man is swinging from a little bit
of webbing and then he swings from that
yeah guys don't forget to subscribe to
the rogue theory podcast feed it comes
out before the videos do stay tuned to
the YouTube channel for the stuff eric
was just talking about and any other
show we have going on follow us on
twitter at new rock stars follow me on
instagram or twitter at philip molina I
love everyone who's still here yeah
sorry Devon
[Music]